[Musique]
à
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
mode d'emploi à gazon bien taillé des
petits drapeaux et des trous partout
vous l'avez deviné je suis sur un
terrain de golf ici pour vous permettre
de pratiquer ce sport de plein air
et pourquoi pas de vous préparer à une
carrière de champion on vous initier ou
vous conseille on vous formate c'est ce
que vous allez voir tout de suite après
votre sommaire aujourd'hui je vous
emmène au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
c'est ici que chaque année se déroule
l'open de france et pour la première
fois en 2018 la célèbre ryder cup au
coeur des préparatifs de ces
compétitions nous allons faire un tour
de parcours des métiers d'intendant de
terrain de responsable clients et
d'enseignants nous partirons ensuite au
golf blue green à lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines à
l'établissement qui recrutent
actuellement nous découvrirons au milieu
de sa grande variété de parcours
le métier de jardinier et pour terminer
nous finirons notre tour des spots avec
le golfe isabella de plaisir ce golf
privé allait beaucoup de charme me
permettra de vous présenter le métier de
directeur de golf et de fontaines is
seen on vous prend de faire un petit
parcours sur 5 ans termine et bien vous
avez de la chance vous l'avez vu dans
votre sommaire l'agglomération accueille
3tera une occasion exceptionnelle de
pratiquer mais également de découvrir de
nombreux métiers dans ce secteur on veut
ça tout de suite de plus près la france
compte 7 135 exploitants d'équipements
sportifs répartis sur tout le territoire
particulièrement riche en espaces verts
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en accueille troyes le golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
blue green à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines et le golf isabella
de plaisir avec treize mille salariés
dont lille directement liée au parcours
de golf
on compte 90 employés dans
l'agglomération yvelinoise le golf
présente une gamme de métiers très
diversifiés répartis en six familles le
terrain avec des métiers tels que
jardinier ou attendant l'accueil vente
avec des postes de responsable sportif
ou pro shop l'administration et
d'encadrement la restauration
l'enseignement et enfin de services aux
joueurs et personnels de service avec
des métiers comme caddie master ou
commissaires de parcours les professions
où les hommes sont en général plus
présent les femmes représentent 46 % des
effectifs à un secteur où les cdi
prédomine
il existe en france 6 130 écoles de golf
et sur saint quentin en yvelines
c'est la fédération française de golf
qui assurent l'enseignement dispensé sur
les courts du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a maintenant vous
savez toujours invite à découvrir en
détail certains de ses métiers pour
commencer en trouant golf national de
guyancourt pour un début de parcours
c'est parti le golf national accueille
entre 5000 et 8000 visiteurs par an du
29 juin au 2 juillet se tiendra comme
chaque année l'open de france
un événement qui accueille plus de 1500
personnes par jour et sollicite
énormément les salariés du golfe
notamment sur le terrain il faut dur sur
les greens et il faut les rendre plus
rapides main un entretien d'excellence
toute l'année et on passe le cinquième
et sixième vitesse pendant deux mois
pour l'open de france et ce travail
d'excellence est effectuée par tout le
staff du terrain avec une expertise
précise 25 jardiniers fontainiers et
mécaniciens tous gérés par alejandro
super intendant du golf national
c'est lui qui doit s'assurer que les
parcourant des conditions optimales pour
les joueurs un travail avant tout de
management motivés motivés l'équipe
chercher la perfection dans chaque
manche à chaque étage est pour moi c'est
ça qui m'a vraiment la différence
on est aussi bon que notre équipe est
motivée
et cadres et il fait bien les choses pas
cool de moyenne
et a entre 60 et 80 hectares de terrain
déclarations gros mental c'est très
intéressant on a on pas le matériel
qu'il faut aussi et maintenant il faut
superviser qu'il faut faire les vidanges
le système d'arrosage
il est aussi au moins sur l'hydraulique
est très important dans notre métier
donc en gros si on a du talent et
management qu'on a mentionné les côtés
agronomique la gestion du matériel
la dystonie draps blick le système
d'arrosage
c'est qu'est ce qui va vous donner une
super entame en un métier multicartes
qui nécessite une forte réactivité des
compétences techniques et de grandes
qualités humaines pour devenir attendant
de golf
il faut être patient et gravir les
échelons c'est impossible de commencer
comme antenne c'est impossible et ça
peut pas marcher
j'ai commencé comme un stadier comme
jardinier c'est la seule manière d
connaissez vraiment parce que comme pour
montrer à notre équipe
comment il faut près si on ne s'est pas
fait la fédération française de golf
propose toutefois une formation en
alternance au centre de formation des
jardiniers des intendants de golf de
dunkerque
quant au salaire d'un attendant il
dépend de la taille de la structure et
de l'expérience la plus grosse
difficulté pour les golf en général et
le recrutement du personnel en cause
directe le travail le week-end mais
beaucoup de golf et la souffre d'une
d'un turnover important du des salariés
parce que le week-end ça pèse à houdain
moment une autre problématique
recrutement aujourd'hui est la notion de
clientèle je pense que les métiers du
golfe ont créé leurs propres problèmes
parce que trop souvent on a embauché des
gens donc prêt à travailler le week-end
accepté les conditions salariés
salariales proposées aimons le golf mais
qui n'aimait pas nécessairement le
client c'est pourquoi depuis trois ans
le golf national a impulsé cette notion
philippe directeur clientèle un post
récent dans le métier à mi chemin entre
le directeur et le responsable et
d'accueil
il est totalement dévoué à la clientèle
il faut être là il faut être au contact
du client peut être il faut lui faire du
welcome faire du sourire faire du
bienvenue et faire l'accompagnement
c'est à dire qu'en fait en gros le
client a lorsqu'il arrive sur site
surtout maintenant une clientèle qui est
étrangère qui vient sur le site pour la
première fois on doit être là pour les
rassurer des guides et désorienté et
faire en sorte qu'une journée ou journée
qu'on pourrait dire banale dans une
structure où il n'y a peut-être pas cet
accompagnement là soit une journée une
journée réussie une journée inoubliable
avec avec ce service la rendre service
clients est primordiale et qu'on arrête
de parler de golfeurs mais qu'on parle
de réellement de clients
philippe est un des rares privilégiés à
ce poste très relationnel trop rares
pour le directeur du golf national
on doit être
leader est à la hauteur des normes des
standards de qualité dans un métier de
services techniques
le golf et requiert une répétition de
gestes quasi mécanique et pour
progresser la porte d'un enseignant est
presque incontournable
vincent est moniteur au sein du golf
national pour lui c'est une vocation
d'enseigner sa demande des qualités
humaines et sa demande comme beaucoup de
beaucoup de passion beaucoup d'empathie
et et avant de transmettre et faire
apprécier discipline à travers son côté
aux autres d'autres joueurs aux autres
personnes une formation accessible à
tous aller qu'au départ un certain
handicap celui du jeu nous avons un jour
de golf ça c'est sûr puisque c'est sa
perte et les tests de sélection et après
effectivement on apprend le métier
d'enseignant animé organiser une
structure une séance prendre son métier
avec tout ce qui est pédagogie être au
service des élèves avec des outils comme
comme les outils pédagogiques comme la
démonstration comme comme les
explications la manipulation aussi
qu'ils sont des supports on apprend à
celle de villa pour eux seulement faire
passer son message et améliorer si
possible le niveau de jeu de ses élèves
en france il existe différents centres
de formation dont la fédération
française de golf qui offre une
formation diplômante en alternance sur
un an
ensuite des formations professionnelles
permettent également d'évoluer vers
d'autres postes
mais on peut passer les diplômes
d'entraîneur qui sont des niveaux plus
élevés qui oriente l'enseignant vais
rien d d d un public plus sportifs
entraînements nous deux en compétition
sur des joueurs de haut niveau sur des
équipes de clubs haut niveau ensuite il
ya une deuxième voie puisque on peut
toujours dans le métier du golfe se
former sur le management et sur nous sur
nos ressources humaines et de gestion
et puis arrivé à des postes de
responsable d'enseignement en encadrant
des équipes d'enseignants annoncées nord
de golf débutera avec un salaire de base
d'environ 1900 euros bruts qui évoluera
selon les compétences poursuivons à
présent notre tour des golf avec le blue
green valley de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
ici on recrute actuellement vous allez
voir sur quel type de poste c'est parti
issue d'une chaîne de golf créé dans les
années 80 le blue green est composée
d'une trentaine de salariés qui
travaillent à la gestion des terrains au
service de la direction clientèle en
restauration et à l'enseignement les
quatre professeurs d'actuels dispense
des cours individuels comme collectifs
et le golfe cherchent un enseignant
supplémentaire en cdi pour compléter son
équipe qu'on recherche
un enseignant qui vient d'avoir son
diplôme soit cette année soit l'année
dernière soit en 2016
moullan bouchons sur une base salariale
de 1900 euros brut
entouré de dix jardiniers le golfe
cherchent également à étendre son équipe
de terrain ce serait un post sur un cdd
de six mois qu'on recherche aujourd'hui
à un junior qui démarrait son expérience
parle sous la responsabilité de la
tendance le jardinier est chargée des
tâches d'entretien et d'aménagement des
parcours lé principal d'activité donc
sont basés essentiellement donc sur les
tout
après il est également amené donc à
ratisser les bunkers donc les bunkers ce
sont des grosses surfaces donc de sable
sans obstacle pour les golfeurs
il est également amené à faire les
bogeys donc ce sont les changements donc
des trous chaque semaine on change le
trou de place papa diverses compétitions
ou même pour le client pour pâques et le
même mot gay a joué près de 6 des tâches
annexes comme le débroussaillage comme
le ramassage de balles sur la zone de
pratique c'est le lieu où les golfeurs
sont reines pour moi la plus grosse de
qualité donc c'est la finesse de ton des
qualités associées à un bep aménagements
paysagers ou une formation de jardiniers
de golf en alternance en centre
horticole ou en lycée agricole le
jardinier pour ensuite évoluer s'il le
souhaite
meyrin poste d'intendant de parcours le
salaire basé sur la convention
collective des golfs permet de démarrer
au smic soit 1400 95 euros brut pour un
travail qui reste néanmoins difficile
la principale difficulté les lançant pas
compte c'est qu'ils estiment qu'on un
travail dans un club qui est magnifique
un comme aujourd'hui fait très très beau
ski se corse un petit peu ça arrive dans
l'hiver voilà on est un travail dans des
températures négatives donc là c'est un
peu plus ennuyeux c'est un travail
physique également pourrait être au
courant également que le jardinier de
golf c'est toute l'année pas qu'on
saison estivale certains postes sont
également possibles sans formation
spécifique par exemple au niveau de
l'accueil où on va avoir des personnes
qui n'ont pas une formation bien
spécifique sur le métier
du chargé de clientèle de l'accueil mais
où on va
la former sur le tas quel que soit le
poste donc la meilleure façon c'est de
l'envoyer d'être de motivation et un cv
les personnes débutantes dans le métier
sont acceptés et en analyse des
candidatures nous terminons à présent
notre tour des parcours avec la visite
du golfe isabella de plaisir
c'est tout de suite à tout d'abord à
vocation familiale le golf isabella
s'est constitué en association sportive
et compte aujourd'hui dix salariés à
tout juste 30 ans son directeur nous
livre son parcours j'ai fait à la fois
un dut de gestion des entreprises et des
administrations en alternance et à côté
de ça j'ai fait quasiment tous les
boulots juste sous le poste de directeur
l'idée c'est justement de ne pas être
spécialiste mais de savoir de quoi on
parle et ce à tous les niveaux
la qualité c'est la prise de recul
l'anticipation et l'organisation des
choses pour ne jamais avoir à réagir ce
poste à haute responsabilité demande des
notions administratives financières et
bien sûr sportive des études de commerce
ou de gestion peuvent donc permettre
déposer ce métier sans mais cette
passion
on est sollicité en permanence puisque
le golf est ouvert 7 sur 7 350 jours par
an on a une notion de management est
très très forte des profils de personnes
qui sont spécialisés dans leur domaine
l'essai d'une c'est une des parties les
plus importants de notre métier
directeur c'est d'être capable de faire
grandir ses spécialités pour qu'ils
apportent plus à l'entreprise et des
spécialités il y en a notamment sur le
terrain l'une des orientations possibles
des jardiniers et de devenir fontainier
et consiste à gérer tout le système
d'arrosage plus spécifiques qu'on ne le
croit cette fonction de nos jardiniers
des compétences particulières ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'il ya quand même
environ 500 arroseurs sur le parcours
donc il faut connaître à peu près leur
place exacte que il faut avoir des
connaissances en plomberie
c'est en plus et en électricité parce
que tout ça c'est géré électroniquement
ce programme et la gestion des arroseurs
lra mettre à niveau font partie des
attributions de ce poste et multitâches
salaire tant elle est aujourd'hui un
problème qui est récurrent sur un des
greens du justement un arroseur qui
était bas niveau donc ce qui provoquait
du dry patch ce sont des tâches sèche dû
à une mauvaise pluviométrie on à
remédier à ces justement aux montants
cet art aux heures pour gagner cette
pluviométrie bien qu'essentielle
n'existe pas de formation en irrigation
propre au golf
néanmoins le centre de dunkerque adapter
une certification des jardiniers
fontainiers aux besoins spécifiques des
zones engazonné à présent tous avaient
tous sur les métiers du golfe
alors si le poste d'intendant parcours
de directeur d'enseignants ou de
jardinier vous a plu je vous donne
rendez vous à la cité des métiers pour
organiser votre parcours professionnel
notez également dans vos agendas deux
ateliers animés par la cité des métiers
de saint quentin en yvelines
le premier vous apprendra à rédiger un
cv et une lettre de motivation
le second vous proposera une simulation
de présentation lors d'un entretien pour
les managers sachez qu'un espace est
ouvert pour vous permettre d'échanger
entre dirigeants une dernière date de
rencontre est prévue le 30 juin la cité
des métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
et pour les organismes de formation
saint quentin en yvelines lance un appel
à labellisation sky écoles de numérique
les établissements intéressés ont
jusqu'au 15 juillet pour candidater à
l'hôtel d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
quant à nous on se retrouve
prochainement pour un nouveau mode
d'emploi mais en attendant prenez soin
de l'autre
[Musique]
à